[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 يطل
عليكم بايقاعه السريع والمختلف ومعلوماته
المباشره ولكن بحله جديده البدايه من
العناوين
الطموح السياسي والخلافات العسكريه
لبرجوشن قد توقف زحفه وزحف باتمر
الاشتباكات المتفرقه تخرق وجودنا السودان
كيف ستتم المراقبه وتحديد المسؤول
وايضا في ملفات الساعه 60
ل واشنطن في سوريا موقفا علني وسري ودمشق
تريد سحبا للقوات الامريكيه
خطروا تيك توك لا يقتصر على الامن
المعلوماتي طفلك قد يكون في خطر
[موسيقى]
عرف سابقا بالغموض وانه لا يظهر كثيرا في
وسائل الاعلام اما الان باتت له مقاطع
مصوره شبه يوميه يتحدث فيها يخاطب الروس
ويخاطب بوتين ويهدد اعدائه كان يفتح شهيه
رئيسه وصديقه على الطعام والان باتت شهيته
مفتوحه لكن على عالم السياسه يبقيني قائد
مجموعه
[موسيقى]
لكن العلاقه بين قائد
وبوتين يبدو انها تاثرت بسبب المعارك التي
كانت دائره في باخموت قبل السيطره الكامله
على المدينه اتصل بجوجن ببوتين للمره
الاولى يشكي له نقص الذخيره بحسب تقرير
النيوزويك اتصالا جاء بعدما باتت العلاقه
مع الجنرالات الروس في حكم المنتهيه
وتحديدا مع وزير الدفاع
وقائد الاركان الاركان فيلاري جراسي موف
اتهموهما بالخيانه وبخداع الرئيس لكن ربما
في هذه الاتهامات ما طال صديقه بوتين
[موسيقى]
من قصد قائد باجنر اذن بالعجوز المحظوظ
بعض الخبراء يرجحون انه يشير الى بوتين
فكيف تدهورت العلاقه الى هذا الحد للاجابه
سنعود الى جذور القصه جلب الكرملين مجموعه
بعد هزيمه قاسيه في ربيع 2022 لتدخل الى
معركه باخمون لكن شهيه السياسيه هي من
حولت البوصله شعر ان قائده بادنر لديه
طموحات اكبر كان يحاول الاستفاده من الحرب
والحصول على مكاسب سياسيه واقتصاديه قاد
عده شكاو بروجين لبوتين كانوا خائفين
ويعتقدون انه يمثل تهديدا للدوله بحسب
شركه
وهي شركه متخصصه في تحليل السياسات
الروسيه هنا استمع بوتين للشكاوى وحاول
تقليل نفوذ بريجوجل
ظهر ذلك في قرار بوتين في اواخر العام
الماضي باعاده غرازيموف وجنرالات اخرين
للواجهه في الحرب الاوكرانيه وهم
المشتبكين مع
وصل الامر لدرجه منع بوتين بروجين من
تجنيد المسجونين في باجنر وهو مكان مسموحا
قد يكون الطموح السياسي اوقف زحف لكن يبدو
ان نجاحاته الاخيره في باخموت واحاديثه
المتتاليه اخيرا منحته شعبيه كبيره
فماذا لو اجريت انتخابات روسيه في اقرب
وقت ممكن لمن سيصوت الروس سؤال طرحه مركز
استطلاع الروسي اسمه نافي حصل بروكوجين في
استطلاعه على
39.7% بينما حصل بوتين على
42.5% الفارق بسيط ومفاجئ
لا يكاد يمر يوما دون ان يدلب ريجوجن قائد
مجموعه العسكريه الخاصه بتصريحات مما
يطالب فيها بتزويده بالسلاح او تتحدث عن
وضع المعارك على الارض في اوكرانيا لتبدا
بعد وسائل اعلام روسيه بالحديث عن امكانيه
ان يكون لديه طموحات سياسيه ايضا في
البلاد اولا بسبب ما يشاع عن وجود خطط
لديه للسيطره على حزب روسيا العادله
لعلاقته المتينه برئيس الحزب سير جيمرنوف
الذي بدوره اكد عدم وجود اي طموحات سياسيه
لدى ثانيا الحديث عن امكانيه انشائه لحركه
محافظه والتي قد تتحول فيما بعد الى حزب
للمزيد ينضم الينا من موسكو الدبلوماسيه
الروسيه الكسندر اهلا بك سيد الكسندر اذا
هذا الجدل المثار حول والذي يثيره هو ايضا
تحديدا اذا ما نظرنا الى تصريحته الاخيره
عن ثوره في روسيا هل هو بدافع العداوه
بالفعل مع شويغو وايضا كراسي ام مسرحيه
ولعبه تكتيكيه تفيد روسيا في مسار الحرب
لا اظن انه في ما يخص بالخلاف مع بين
الجيش وزير الدفاع ورئيس اركان هذا الواقع
وينبع صحيح من سر العمليات وجود موضوع
الزخاير
والدور في مخموض كله خلق الواقع لنحن
نعرفه
العظم اليوم خديس يجري ليس عن هذا الخلاف
بل عن
ممكن معقول الجانب السياسي
لهذا الامر لانه برايي انه روسيه اليوم
تعيش تصورات هامه جدا في كافه المجالات
وليس فقط هنا الجانب العسكري
وعظمهم لانه
[موسيقى]
هناك نظريه الجيش
كانت خلال كل
السنوات وجود
روسيا الجديده عنه مطلوب جيش متواضع قادر
فقط
كل هذا سيد اليكساندر هل يبحث بروجوجل عن
نفوذ سياسي ويعني ما هي حدوده في هذه يعني
المطامع اذا ما تحدثنا ايضا عن خلافه
الواضح مع جنرالات
صحيح
منذ الفتره كانت ممكن نقول انه هموم
كانت
تقتصر
شركه
ليس فقط في روسيا والاماكن اخرى
ولكن في ظروف التي انا ليس بصدفه اشارتي
للظروف تعيش روسيا بشكل كامل الله في غازي
ظروف
الاطماع
المجالات عديده ليس فقط المجال العسكري
وهناك جانب سياسي مهم اصبح هذا هو الواقع
حدث سريعا جدا
ربما نتيجه
التطورات
حول مجموعه ولكن
عنا سيناريو
المثال تتحدث عن امكانيه امداد بروجن
الاوكرانيين باحداثيات روسيه وتفاصيل خاصه
بالجانب الروسي بما يتعلق بالحرب
لا انا لا اريد ان اتحدث حول المقالات في
اعلام الغربي
هذا راي الام عضو فلذلك ما فيش مجال
لتعليق عليها نحن نتحدث حول معه يجري في
روسيا
انا لا افهم هذا المنطق الله هناك
وهناك نحن نرى مواقف
تتعلق بالاوضاع في روسيا
لديه بعض الافكار وهو يطرح هذه الافكار
اما الاشياء
المكتوبه في
اعلام عدو لا اريد ان نناقشها
فلتتفضل بالبقاء معنا السيد الكساندر
سنستمع لما قاله قائد قوات باجنار حول
تحذيره من ثوره في روسيا على غرار ثوره
1917 اذا لم تتحرك النخبه لتدارك الوضع
وبالمناسبه المدون الروسيه الذي اجرى
المقابله مع بريجوجل قال انه تم طرده من
الشركه الاعلاميه التي يعمل فيها بسبب هذه
المقابله وهذلك بحسب واشنطن بوست
بينما يموت الناس على الجبهات صهر وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي سفر للاستجمام كل هذه
الانقسامات يمكن ان تنتهي الى الثوره كما
حدث في عام 1917
رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي هو الاخر
قام بمقابله صحفيه يوم امس ابرز ما جاء
فيها كان اقتراح تقسيم اوكرانيا كانت
نتيجه محتمله للحرب بحيث ينضم الشرق الى
روسيا ويتم دمج مناطق في الغرب في العديد
من الدول الاعضاء بالاتحاد الاوروبي كما
اكد بانه في حال زود الغرب اوكرانيا
باسلحه نوويه فحينها ستحتاج روسيا الى
توجيه ضربه استباقيه واشار الى انه يوجد
قوانين حرب لا رجعت فيها اذا تعلق الامر
بالاسلحه النوويه اذا نعود الى ضيفنا
الكساندرز الدبلوماسيه الروسي يعني
تصريحات نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي الرئيس الروسي السابق متفيدب ذهب
فيها الى ما هو ابعد من حرب الاستنزاف
تحدث عن استخدام الاسلحه النوويه مجددا
ولكن ايضا تحدث عن اختفاء اوكرانيا من على
الخريطه يعني اساسا هناك ح رب جاريه في
اوكرانيا ما الذي تريده موسكو اكثر
اولا انه موضوع تقسيم اوكرانيا هذا ليس
اختراع
غازي الافكار منتشره هنا وهناك في الاعلام
وما بين الاوساط السياسيه والى اخره
لكن
اليوم من المستحيل
ان نحدد ما هي فعلا
ان تقوم النتائج
للهازيه
الى وين
توصل الامور هذا مستحيل هذا الراي مدريديف
ربما
ولكن لا لا ارى شيء جديد في هذه الافكار
موضوع سلاح النووي هذا صحيح هذا خط احمر
وهذا معروف
نعتقد انه
وسوف يزاوط اوكرانيا بكل انواع السلاح قدر
الامكان سلاح متطور
دبابات صواريخ طائرات ولكن الله ليست
سلاحا النوويزا حادث فطبعا يكون خط احمر
هذا
الحرب الى مراحل مختلفه نعم اشكرك جزيل
الشكر عذرا السيد الكسندر داهمنا الوقت
شكرا لكم
يوما مرت على معركه الذبح في بخموت بحسب
وصف واشنطن حتى سيطرت روسيا على المدينه
قوه باجنر بقياده بريكوشن بدات تسليم
المدينه للدفاع الروسيه لكن ماذا بعد
الواقعه شرق اوكرانيا تقع على بعد نحو 65
كيلو مترا شمال مدينه دانياس وعلى بعد 15
كيلومترا عن حدود بالسيطره عليها يمكن ان
تكون خطوه روسيا التاليه التقدم غربا
والسيطره على السبيانس وكرامه وهو ما يعني
ان الجيش الروسي سيكون امامه طريق مفتوح
للسيطره على باقي دومباس القتال الذي
خاضته روسيا في بخموت حتى سيطرت عليها تم
تقسيمه لمحورين بعد فشل القوات في تطبيق
القوات الاوكرانيه داخل المدينه كلفت قوات
باجنار باقتحام المدينه من الشرق وصولا
للغرب عبر القتال في الشوارع ام ر جعل
تكلفه الانتصار عاليه جدا فيما تكفل الجيش
الروسي بحمايه المدينه شمالا وجنوبا حيث
كانت الاشتباكات في الحقول والقرى هذه
الاستراتيجيه جعلت روسيا تسيطر كليا على
باخموت بما يفيدها في منع الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد
نحن ندرك انه بعد بخمت بامكانهم الذهاب
ابعد من ذلك الى كروماتور وسلوفيانسك
سيكون الطريق مفتوحا امام الروس الى مدن
اخرى في اوكرانيا باتجاه ديونيتسك
بالمنطق العسكري وبحسب عدد من المحللين
العسكريين لا يحتاج الجيش الروسي الان الى
فيغنر وخصوصا بعد السيطره على بخموت
مقاتلوها مرهقون معنوياتهم منخفضه وهنا
يحاول بريغوجن تقويه المجموعه واخيرا ظهرت
تقارير تتحدث عن انضمام الجنرال روما نائب
القائد السابق للحرس الوطني الروسي
والجنرال ميخائيل
نائب وزير الدفاع السابق الى باجنار بعد
اقالتهما من الخدمه المدنيه لكن قد يكون
هذا الامر مقدمه او بدايه استيلاء على
باجنر من قبل الكريمليل وذلك بحسب بلاد
الميكانينكو الخبير في الشؤون الروسيه
فكره اخرى تقلقوش وانتقد الكرملين علنا
بسببها الشهر الماضي انشاء شركات عسكريه
خاصه جديده بدلا من دعم داكنر
موجودين
ليكون السؤال الان ماذا لو استمر
في انتقاداته للكرملين
العسكريين السيناريوهات عديده احداها تخلص
[موسيقى]
ات في سياستها في السودان في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تحول الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد من مصدر صداع الى ضغط نفسيا على
الجيش الاوكراني فقدان السيطره على
الاجواء جعل مهمه نقل الاسلحه الغربيه
الثقيله الى الداخل الاوكراني مهمه صعبه
مواجهه التحدي تحصلت اوكرانيا على العديد
من انظمه الدفاع الغربيه الا ان اهمها
يبقى نظام باتريت بعيد المدى وهو عماد
الدفاع الجوي الامريكي الذي بات يواجه
للمره الاولى ظروف حرب حقيقيه تضررت
المنظومه قبل ايام بضربات الروسيه فكيف تم
الامر
بالقربه من مطاري كيا بالدولي نصب نظام
باتريات بهدف توفير دفاع بعيد المدى يغطي
كل مناطق كياب ومن اجل توفير دفاع طبقي
متماسك وضعت انظمه
قصيره المدى انظمه قديمه لكنها حل اقتصادي
لحمايه باتريا باهظه الثمن من هجوم
المسيرات باتريوت ومنذ دخوله اوكرانيا
تحول الى هدف موسكو الاول وبدون تحديده لن
تتمكن من استخدام الصواريخ والمسيرات غير
المكلفه التي تستنزف دفاعات اوكرانيا
صواريخ باتريا يتصل سرعتها الى 3 ماخ اي
ثلاث مرات السرعه الصوت واذا ما استثنينا
صاروخ اسكندر الذي لا يصل مداه كيب فلم
يبقى في ترسانه موسكو الا كنجال الذي تصل
سرعته لعشر ماخ ثلاث مرات اسرع من صواريخ
باتريوت عدم القدره على
لا يعني عدم رصده في الرادار طاقم
الباتريوت تعرف عليه من خلال دراسه سرعته
لكن وقت وصوله للهدف لن يتعدى دقيقه واحده
وهو زمن لا يكفي لتغيير موقع باتريوت وهنا
قرر الطاقم المشغل اطلاق كل الصواريخ في
الفراغ سته وثلاثون صاروخا في المجموع
بهدف تخفيف قوه الانفجار ومنع امتداده
للبطاريات الاخرى ثوان بعدها واصل كنجال
الى هدفه وسقط بين الرادار واحدى
البطاريات واشنطن لم تنفي تضرر بات لاول
مره في حرب حقيقيه لكن روسيا اضطرت
لاستخدام صاروخها الاغلى وبذلك دخلت موسكو
و واشنطن مرحله اخرى من حرب الاستنزاف
والمكان
[موسيقى]
اكثر من شهر على الحرب في السودان حيث
النزاع بين الجيش بقياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان والدعم السريع لقياده حمى ثمانيه
هدى انسانيه توصل اليها الطرفان لكنها
خرقت كل منها بنسب متفاوته والحصيله من كل
هذا
865 قتيلا من المدنيين واكثر من ثلاثه
الاف جريح رغم ان الارقام مرتفعه لكن من
المحتمل ان تكون الارقام الحقيقيه اعلى من
ذلك بكثير فاغلب الضحايا بطبيعه الحال
سقطوا في نقطه الصراع المركزي الخرطوم
مبروك
الوضع في السودان معقد للغايه ويبدو عصيا
عن الحل بحسب الكثيرين ومن بينهم جوزيف
بوريل مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي برايه لا توجد اراده لدى طرفي
الصراع في حل سياسي لكن دعونا نلقي نظره
على خريطه المعارك بعد اكثر من شهر على
النزاع في ولايه الخرطوم مركز المعارك
الرئيسي السيطره منقسمه بين الطرفين في
مدن ولايه الولايه الثلاث الخرطوم بحري
والخرطوم العاصمه وانظر من في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري يسيطروا الدعم السريع على
غالبيه اجزاء المدينه حيث تنتشر في منطقه
الخرطوم بحري وجنوب الخرطوم في مدينه
الخرطوم العاصمه مازال صراع السيطره على
مطار الخرطوم الدولي الدائرا بين الطرفين
يسيطر الجيش على الجزء الاكبر من القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه بينما تتواجد قوات
الدعم السريع في جزء من القياده العامه
اما في ام درمان يسيطر الجيش السوداني على
اغلب مناطق المدينه بينما تسيطر قوات
الدعم السريع على مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون
والذي تعرض محيطه لقصف جويا قوي قبل دخول
الهدنه حيز التنفيذ في ظل سعي الجيش
للسيطره عليه
امل كبيره يعقدها السودانيون على المبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه والتي افضت الى
اتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق النار بين الجيش
والدعم السريع لمده سبعه ايام تنتهي بعد
غد الاحد مع امكانيه تجديدها لكن التحدي
الاكبر يبقى ضمان التزام الطرفين بوقف
اطلاق النار خلقت الهدنه على فترات متقطعه
خلال الايام الماضيه لكن بشكل اقل حده
ووطئه منذ قبل لذا تضمنت الاتفاقيه بندا
ينص على انشاء لجنه مراقبه وتنسيق وقف
لوقف اطلاق النار تتالف من ثلاثه ممثلين
لكل من الطرفين المتنازعين وثلاثه ممثلين
لكل من الرياض وواشنطن
اذا اللجنه لمراقبه وتنسيق وقف اطلاق
النار تضم ممثلين عن الطرفين الى جانب
ممثلين من الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه
توفر اللجنه منصه لاستقبال الشكاوى وحل
النزاعات المتعلقه بالدعاءات وقوع
انتهاكات على ان تقوم بالتحقق من وقوع
الانتهاكات كيف تعتمد اليه المراقبه على
التقاط صور جويه بعضها عبر بيانات الاقمار
الصناعيه وذلك الى جانب تحليل منشورات
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وتقارير ميدانيه
من اعضاء المجتمع المدني في السودان بحسب
قناه سي ان ان في حال تاكد خرق احد
الطرفين لبنود الهدنه يتم اخطاره بذلك
وتحديده بشكل علني ومطالبته بمحاسبه من ثم
ومن ارتكب هذا الانتهاك خاصه في الجرائم
والتجاوزات
الجسيمه الوضع في السودان اسهم في
انتقادات للمجتمع الدولي بشكل عام وواشنطن
بشكل خاص والسبب هو عدم تقديم دعم كافن
لانجاح تجربه الحكم الديمقراطي في السودان
منذ 2019 وحتى اواخر 2020 قضت واشنطن هذا
الوقت في بحث قرار رفع السودان من قائمه
الدول الراعيه للارهاب يتاخر توفير الدعم
المالي لحكومه عبد الله حمدوك وبالتالي
عرقله خطته
لتحسين حياه السودانيين وبالتالي انخفضت
شعبيه الحكومه المدنيه خاصه مع وصول نسبه
التضخم الى
359 في عام 2021 عدد من التقارير الغربيه
الاعلاميه
وغيرها القت باللوم على صناع القرار في
واشنطن وعلى وثوقهم بالطرفي النزاع ونقلت
التقارير غضب عدد من الدبل وماسيين
والمسؤولين من الاداره الامريكيه الذين
راوا ان هذه السياسه ايضا فاقمت التوترات
بين الجنرلين وتجاهلت القوه المدنيه وهذا
بجانب عوامل اخرى اثرت على السياسه
الامريكيه السودان
[موسيقى]
خياراته واشنطن السودان كانت محدوده بحسب
الدبلوماسيه قديه كان عليها اشراك الجيش
وقوات الدعم في الحوار وهنا التعتيرات لمن
كان مبعوث امريكا الى القرن الافريقي
السياسه الامريكيه في السودان اجملها
مسؤول امريكي سابق رفض الكشف عن اسمه في
تصريحات اجملها كالتالي الولايات المتحده
بنت قصر احلام من العمليات السلميه تحطمت
الان على الشعب السوداني
[موسيقى]
للمزيد ينضم الينا في الاستوديو عثمان
بوني رئيس تحالف قوى الخلاص الوطنيه اهلا
بك كل الهدن في السودان تخرق من كلا
الطرفين هذه الهدنه هذه المره برعايه
سعوديه امريكيه واسس لها لجنه لمراقبه وقف
اطلاق النار وتبدو اكثر استقرارا لكن ما
هي اليه هذه اللجنه هل اتضحت بالضبط
اولا تحياتي لك ولمشاهدينك الكرام
بالحقيقه هي يعني الخطوه الامريكيه
السعوديه منذ البدايه نحن يمكن تحدثنا عده
مرات هي خطوه يمكن اعلان كان اعلان فضفاض
لانه هذه يمكن يعني المره السابعه يحصل
اختراق للهدنه الموجوده في السودان نسبه
لانه الهدنه المفروض يعني في المقام الاول
يكون فيه اليه رقابيه على الارض وليس
ارليه رغابيه عبر الجو عبر الاقمار
الاصطناعيه وخلافه لانه يتم الحديث عنه هل
الادوات التكنولوجيه
ستشكل عائق ا على مراقبه هذه الهدنه نعم
اولا المراقبه عبر الاخبار الاصطناعيه هي
ممكن يقدر يعني يرغب مثلا الطيران يرغب
المسيرات يعني الاشياء المدفعيه هكذا ولكن
المشاه مين راح يراقبهم بالاضافه لانه حتى
الاقمار الاصطناعيه لو مثلا انه يعني عملت
اي صور ولا خلافه الصور يعني راح تتحول
لجهه معينه عشان يحللوا الصور يعرفوا
بمصداقياتهم مواعيدها وكذا ثم بعد ذلك
يعني يصدر غرار يعني راح يكون فيها تمويج
في الزمن فبالتالي نحن طالبنا انه تكون في
اليه رقابيه على الارض موجوده ونحن في
تحالف الخلاصه الوطني اعلنا مبادره سابقا
وهذه المبادره شامله لانهاء هذا الصراع في
السودان وتم قبوله في الجامعه العربيه في
جامعه الدول العربيه وفي الاتحاد الافريقي
ونحن ايضا يعني ان اشدنا المبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه انه يعني
تجميع هذه المبادرات الاقليميه والمحليه
في منصه واحده على اساس ان يكون يعني
شامله للجميع وينهي هذا الصراع اللجنه
ايضا معنيه بتوصيل المساعدات الانسانيه
الامم المتحده تحدثت للعربيه
وقالت الهدنه لو استمرت بشكل كافي لسبعه
ايام فسيتم توصيل مساعدات لاربعه ملايين
شخص في السودان هل برايك من ما هو مرصود
على الارض هل هذا ممكنا يعني هو الان الان
الصليب الاحمر يمكن يعني استغل الهدنه
الموجوده وابتدى الصليب الاحمر وصل يعني
مساعدات للمستشفيات في الخرطوم خلال
اليومين الماضيين وصلت يعني حوالي سبعه
ثمانيه مستشفيات ولكن نحن نرى انه لابد ان
تكون اليه الرقابيه على الارض وهي التي
تحدد المسارات الامنه للمواطنين وايضا
تحددا الخروقات لو حصل اي فروغات من اي
طرف من الاطراف هل يمكن لهذه الاليه ان مع
استمرارها تجديدها والالتزام اكثر بها هل
يمكن ان تؤسس لحل سياسي للجلوس للتفاوض هل
تراها ناجعه الى هذه الطريقه اراها ان
يعني يعني ده تضيع بتاع زمن ساكن نحن نرى
انه الان ما في داعي يعني سؤال الامريكان
او السعوديين الان لا بد ان يكون انه
عندهم حلول شامله كامله لابد ان يكون
هنالك معسكرات لتجميع قوات الدعم السريع
وخروج هم الان يطالبوا تخرج من الاماكن
اللي هي يعني محتلها المستشفيات او
المرافق الخدميه الى اين سوف تذهب لا بد
ان يحدد لها مثلا معسكرات معين ويكون هم
تحت اشراف المجتمع الدولي هذه المعسكرات
فبالتالي في ذلك الزمن يعني ممكن ان تخرج
قوات الدعم السريع من المناطق اللي هي
فيها وتروح الى
المعسكرات المحدده الينا ايضا السيد عثمان
سينضم الينا
عبر سكايب من واشنطن مايكل مالري مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق يعني
الخارجيه اهلا بك اولا الخارجيه الامريكيه
قالت ان كلى طرفي النزاع قام بخرق الهن
لكن ماذا بعد المراقبه والرصد هل تتحرك
واشنطن مع المعطيات الموجوده لديها التي
قالت انها موجوده والخارجيه ايضا تقول
انها تمتلك كل الادوات للتعامل مع
الانتهاكات وانها لن تتردد في استخدامها
ما هي هذه الادوات
في الفتره الحاليه وزاره الخارجيه ما ترغب
فعله هو ان تصمد هذه الهدنه فهناك حاج
مساعدات الانسانيه يجب التعامل معها وخاصه
بالنسبه للاشخاص النازحين وهذه هي الفتره
المثلى لاجراء المفاوضات حول المستقبل
البلاد والعوده الى العمليه الديمقراطيه
بالنسبه لاليه الرصد والمراقبه فاقول
باننا نحتاج
لكل الدعم
الولايات المتحده
والمبادره مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يمكنه ان تنظر الى صور الاقمار الصناعيه
واستخدام المسيراتي للوقوف على الجهه التي
تقوم بارتكاب تلك الانتهاكات
والتي تقوم بتاجيج المواجهات وبعد ذلك سوف
يمكن الزج بقوه من الام بموظفينا من الام
على الارض لرصد هذه الانتهاكات بناء على
ما يحدث الان استطيع ان اقول ان عمليه
تحليل هذه الوقائع سوف تدفعنا لاتخاذ
قرارات بشان ادخال جهه على الارض واجراء
الاتصالات المطلوبه الولايات المتحده سوف
تعمل على تطبيق هذه الهدنه هدنه الرقابه
في مرحله اولياء
اذا سمحت لي كان يتحدث ضيفي هنا عثمان
بوني يقول ان هذه الادوات ليست كافيه صور
الاقمار الصناعيه وانت كنت الان تتحدث عن
الارسال فريق من الامم المتحده للمراقبه
ولكن هذا في ظل صراع قائم صراع مشتعل الى
اي مدى قد يخدم
الصراع السودانيين لحل الصراع ولانقاذ
الارواح ايضا
مثاليه ولا اعلم صراحه ما هو الحل وخاصه
بالنسبه للتوقيت والاوضاع التي يعيشها
السودان
الامور تبدو انها في
ذروه تعقيدتها ولكن يمكن استخدام المسيرات
ومن خلال الاشخاص الموجودين على الارض
يمكنهم ان يقدموا معلومات مهمه وليس
الاعتماد على اطراف ثالثه او اطراف خارجيه
للوقوف على من ينتهكوا تلك الهدنه وهذا
يساعدنا على اتخاذ قرارات بناء على
المعلومات التي يتم تلقيها ومن ثم يؤمل من
قبل كل من الطرفين ان ياخذهم لان هذا ما
يحتاجه الشعب السودان وهذا قد وهذا ايضا
يقضي بان الجزء من الهدنه يقضي بالخروج من
بعض الاماكن كما جاء في معرض التقريركم
مثل المستشفيات
فلابد لكافه القوات العسكريه التي تتخذ من
المستشفيات مقرا لها ان تخرج منها من اجل
وتفادي استهدافها وبكل تاكيد هذا قد ادى
الى عرقله وخدمه المستشفيات والمستشفيات
ايضا والتي يجب ان لا تكون مقرا لاي من
الطرف معنا من واشنطن مايكل مالري مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق وايضا كنت
معنا في الاستوديو السيد عثمان اباولين
رئيس تحالف قوى الخلاص الوطني شكرا لكما
مبروك
[موسيقى]
قعدت سوريا لشغله مقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه وحضر الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
قمه تجدده حققت حققت القمه اهدافها طبعا
واجه هذا القرار ردود افعال واسعه واشنطن
كانت ابرز المنتقدين برات ان سوريا لا
تستحق ذلك لكن رغم هذا الانتقاد في العلم
ظاهره تقارير امريكيه وتناولت ما حدث في
الخفاء تسالون امريكيون اجروا محادثات
مباشره مع وفد سوري في العاصمه العمانيه
مسقط ضمت هذه اللقاءات شخصيات امنيه من
البلدين وممثلين عن وزارات الخارجيه
ماذا دار في اللقاء اولا ضغط المسؤولون
السوريون بشكل اساسي من اجل الانسحاب
الكامل للقوات الامريكيه في سوريا
وثانيا جدد المبعوث الامريكي التاكيد على
انه لديه معلومات تفيد بان الصحفي
الامريكي
معتقل في مكان اتابع للجيش السوري الوفد
السوري اصر على انه لا يمتلك اي معلومات
عن الامر لكنه شدد على ان دمشق مستعده
لبذل كل الجهود للكشف عن مصيره بحسب
التقارير الامريكيه الموضوع الوحيد الذي
لم يتم التطرق اليه هو مصير القوات
المدعومه من الولايات المتحده مثل قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه لكن لماذا ردت واشنطن
على هذه التقارير
كان ليس منهم كان يؤكد ان كان او لم يكن
اي مفاوضات في عمان وفي اي مكان اخر من
الممكن ان نحن نبذل الولايات المتحده هذه
الاداره تبدل كل ما في وسعها لاعاده الى
منزله انا لا اقول ان اي من هذه هي تفاصيل
صحيحه ام لا اذا الولد المتحده لديها
الامكانيه لتقوم بمفاوضات حول المواطنين
الامريكيين المعتقلين تعسفيا او مفقودين
بدون اي تعثرات على سياساتنا
الاتصالات السريه سبق وان حدثت خلال عهد
ترامب كان النقاش يدور ايضا حول امكانيه
ان تسحب واشنطن قواتها العسكريه من سوريا
لم يتحقق الامر في عهد ترامب بل ان
الاتصالات انقطعت تماما بعد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق في قتل الاسد وهو ما منعه
ما هو معارضه وزير دفاعه وقتها جيمس ترامب
هو من صرح بذلك وعلنا
كنت افضل قتله لقد جهزت للامر تماما لم
يرغب في ان يفعل ذلك ماتسكن جنرالا بلغ في
تقديره لقد تركته يرحل لقد عمل مع اوباما
وتمت اقالته من قبل اوباما ايضا
عدم وجود رغبه واشنطن في انهاء وجودها
في ما هي اولوياتها هناك اذا نهايه عام
2021 وعقبا مراجعه الحكومه الامريكيه
سياساتها تجاه سوريا حددت بعض الاولويات
اهمها الحفاظ على زخم مكافحه داعش وضمان
عدم عودته ويشمل ذلك تدريب وتسليح
المقاتلين الاكراد وقوات قصد
يستمر القتال في هذه المرحله ضد داعش انت
تعلم انه يمكننا باستمرار ان نضعف قدراتهم
الخاصه بالقياده والسيطره وقدراتهم على
الاستيلاء على اي ارض والسيطره عليها
هذه الاولويه الخاصه بداعش تشكك بها روسيا
صاحبه الوجود العسكريه الوازن في سوريا
ومنذ ثمان سنوات بالنظر الى تدهور قوه
وقدره داعش بشكل كبير اولويه واشنطن هذه
ايضا تعرضها تركيا من جهه اخرى التي تتحفظ
على كل ما من شانه زياده النفوذ الكردي
على حدودها الجنوبيه او زياده قوه الاكراد
بالدعم الامريكي اولويه اخرى لواشنطن في
سوريا لكن هذه المره تحدثت عنها
النقط السوريه
الجيش الامريكي لا يزال يحتل المناطق
الخاصه بانتاج الحبوب والنفط الرئيسيه في
سوريا وينهب الثروات الوطنيه السوريه مما
يفقهم الازمه الانسانيه المحليه
تتفاوضوا امريكا مع سوريا سرا لمراجعه
الوجود العسكري وفي وقت يؤكد البيت الابيض
عدم التراجع عن الانتشار المستمر منذ ما
يقرب من ثماني سنوات في سوريا وذلك بعد ان
صوت مجلس النواب الامريكي برفض قرار سحب
القوات الامريكيه من سوريا
سوطاثه مشرعين لصالح القرار
و321 ضده اول دفعه من القوات الامريكيه
جاءت في اكتوبر عام 2015 وبلغ عددها 50
جنديا من القوات الخاصه دورهم كان
استشاريا لا قتليا نهايه عام 2016 وصل
العدد الى 500 جندي واليوم 900 هو الرقم
المعلن رسميا هؤلاء ينتشرون في المنطقه
المعروفه باسم منطقه شرق سوريا الامنيه
ضمن محافظتي الحسكه
ودير الزور
تيك توك تبدا في منحي امريكا ما يخفف من
مخاوفها في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد القلق من مخاطر تيك توك
احدى النوادر التي اتفق عليها الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي في واشنطن المخاوف
جاءت بسبب وجود قوانين تسمح لبكين
بالمطالبه سرا ببيانات من شركاتها
ومواطنها لاهداف استخباراتيه القلق يتعظم
منذ ديسمبر الماضي حين اعترفت الشركه
المالكه للتطبيق
الموظفيها وصلوا الى بيانات حسابات صحفيين
في محاوله لاكتشاف مصادرهم وهو ما جعل تيك
توك يطلق مشروع
وهو خطه لتطويق بيانات المستخدمين
الامريكيين والسماح بمراجعه التقنياتها من
قبل شركاء مثل شركه اوركل لتقييم المخاطر
الامنيه حيث اتاح تيك توك لاركل الوصول
الكامل الى شيفره المصدر الخوارزميات
الخاصه بها لكن حتى بتوافق الحزبيه على
الحظر على الاجهزه
لا ضمانات لواشنطن لاستخدام السلطات
التنفيذيه والتنظيميه والقانونيه لمسح تيك
توك من هواتف 150 مليون مستخدم امريكي
فمنعوا الامريكيين من استخدام تطبيق يسمح
لهم بمشاركه ارائهم ومواهبهم سيواجه
تحديات قانونيه على اسس التعديل الاول من
الدستور الامريكي والذي يضمن حق حريه
التعبير سيناريو حدث بالفعل في مونتانا
اول ولايه تحضر التطبيق رفعت مجموعه من
صناع المحتوى دعوى قضائيه لالغاء الحظر
الشامل متهمين حاكم الولايه انتهاك
الدستور اما بالنسبه لمقترح اداره بايدن
ببيع تيك توك لشركه امريكيه بدلا من حظره
التام فبكين على موقفها منذ عهد ترامب
تفضل اغلاق التطبيق
على بيعها
عندما انظر للحظر فان الامر يعكس لاحباطا
كبيرا على مستوى الحكومه ليظهر انهم
يتخذون خطوات والاهم من ذلك هو الاشاره
الى الجهات المعنيه بانهم تحركوا بغض
النظر عما اذا كان تحركهم قابلا للتطبيق
ام لا
مخاطر التطبيق الصيني لا تقتصروا على
الامن المعلوماتيه فحسب بل هناك ما هو
اخطر صحه الاطفال والمراهقين
خوارزميات تيك توك احدى اهم عوامل نجاحه
واليوم احدى اهم النقاط التي يستخدمها
منتقد التطبيق الصيني تعرض محتوى تعرض
محتوى مشابها للمستخدمين للمستخدمين في كل
مره يزورون فيها المنصه بحيث يتم تخصيص
محتوى محدد لهم بالمعنى الحرفي يتشاركونه
مع نظرائهم من اصحاب الاهتمام المشترك على
سبيل المثال وبحسب مركز مكافحه الكراهيه
الرقميه تم انشاء حسابات وهميه لاطفال في
السن 13 عاما شاهدت الحسابات مقطع فيديو
عن فقدان الوزن او معاناه شخص من زياده
الوزن فما لبث تيك توك ان اقترح عليه
مقاطع فيديو لصوره الجسد والصحه العقليه
امر يحدث كل 39 ثانيه ولهذا يتهم البعض
التيك توك بالمسؤوليه عن تعرض الكثير من
الاطفال والمراهقين الاضطرابات في الاكل
والاكتئاب واحيانا الانتحار فما هو رد
التطبيق
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بذلك نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
ملفاتنا لليوم وتتابعونا في حلقه السبت من
الساعه 60 اردوغان او الجدار اوغلو من
سيكتب التاريخ في الانتخابات التركيه
الخلافات السياسيه يمكن ان تتسبب في تخلف
تاريخي لامريكا عن سداد الديون من الان
وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين الشولي وهذه
الساعه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات